[Musique]
un architecte m'a inspiré ce problème la
courbe à nos enfants du nord furtif
énigmatique silencieux cultivant son
mystère au souffle du chaud et en
cherchant dans les volutes de sauge une
rédemption libératrice marche comme du
quart et ses territoires habités du
respect des rites anciens avec le don de
sculpter le vide de l'espace
pour ces peuples oubliés du temps bien
avant les premiers contacts avec les
européens les peuples autochtones
étaient pour la plupart normal ils
vivaient sur un vers ce territoire au
rythme des saisons
la financiarisation et ses constructions
uniformiser on est un puissant vecteur
de colonisation un allié du génocide
culturel avoir cet extrait du
documentaire d'arthur lamotte le passage
des tentes aux maisons c'est encore le
cas
l' architecture peut-elle nous aider à
renverser la vapeur
car il y a une architecture plus
attentive aux particularités régionales
plus sensible à la diversité des
communautés autochtones
je ne suis pas tombé dans le monde de
l'architecturé par passion par vocation
je connaissais très peu ce monde
pour moi les architectes étaient des
gens peu sociaux toujours pencher sur
leurs pattes et quadrillé habillés de
noir et tourmenté
aujourd'hui j'y travaille mes préjugés
n'était pas vraiment fonder les
architectes ne sont pas seulement des
gens avenants
il porte également de l'eau de
responsabilité et voit le monde avec un
oeil d'artiste mon regard sur le
patrimoine bâti a également changé
avant je ne portait aucune attention mon
environnement
je ne me reconnaissais pas dans cette
architecture alors j'ai traversé la
ville la tête penchée
mais voilà aujourd'hui attentive hostile
à la finition des immeubles au détail
aux différents ce qui leur donne son
caractère distinctif dans le métro de
montréal je remarque par exemple comment
les oeuvres d'art sont intégrés en même
la structure des stations et des tunnels
c'est une architecture qui parle aux
passants qui fait résonner la voix des
artistes et mme en valeur la beauté la
diversité de la ville pour les peuples
autochtones l' architecture est un
rendez vous manqué oui l'architecturé
moderne leur a proposé des solutions
universelles uniforme fade sans couleur
carré comment pouvons nous différencier
l' architecture de la nation waits ou
étonne de la nation dénée with you les
attikameks comment rendre hommage à
leurs particularités culturelles
s'il ya eu tentative de les faire
disparaître et de gommer tout différence
nous étions des peuples habitant un
vaste territoire dans une recherche
d'harmonie d' équilibre avec la mise en
réserve tel qu'autorisé par la loi sur
les indiens
nous avons été sédentarisés de force et
nous avons dû apprendre à habiter une
maison un espace restreint
confiné l'adaptation a été difficile
voire même traumatisante
on peut même dire que nous avons
commencé à contre habiter le territoire
à l'habiter à contrecoeur
je me souviens de mes voyages dans
différentes communautés innu ma nation
ou un banshee poupe akwasi pourquoi ni
cheat
je n'y étais pas dépaysés mais j'étais
incapable de me développer un sentiment
d'appartenance
privé de ma propre histoire car elle ne
m'avait pas été enseigné tout me
semblait étrange et même si j'ai passé
les huit premiers jours de ma vie sous
une tente
un exemple frappant ses trois arrêts au
garden du nunavik même modèle rien de
particulier ne les distingue aujourd'hui
rénover les trois fers et au regard
contribuer à l'affirmation identitaire
d'isigny est heureuse et bienvenus
ces communautés qui ne sont joignables
que par avion arrivé par des arrêts aux
gars orné de symboles culturels qui leur
ressemble
comble de l'arctique pour kangirsuk les
bélougas pourquoi ctaq je vais y revenir
et pour finir le lagopède des neiges
pour tester yak que ce soit par la forme
les couleurs ses oeuvres d'art met en
valeur des animaux qui sont au coeur de
la vie culturelle et traditionnelle de
chaque communauté dans l'uniformité la
grisaille
c'est impossible de se reconnaître
comment inverser cette tendance
comment redonner un supplément d'âme aux
lieux habités par les communautés
autochtones
comment le faire de manière non
intrusive non agressive curiosité et
respect sont des conditions essentielles
pour y parvenir
curiosité et respect pour découvrir
l'histoire des premières nations et
désigner cette histoire orale qui n'est
pas écrit curiosité et respect pourtant
l'oreille et s'ouvrir au partage des
gardiens du territoire on ouvre le
dialogue
en sortant de sa zone de confort un peu
comment avec vous asseoir
en dix ans démystifier larchitecture
avec une approche tranquille à l'ecoute
en ne laissant personne qui plus est le
monde de l'architecturé comme déjà aux
portes des communautés autochtones
cette évolution est le fruit d'un
mouvement d'affirmation identitaire
comme elle donne aux morts de nombreuses
confréries confrontation sociale
on veut trouver un équilibre positif au
travers des rencontres des dialogues des
revendications des demandes de
reconnaissance territoriale humaine
l'architecturé adaptée fait son petit
bonhomme de chemin de manière paisible
larchitecture marque à sa façon le
territoire notre hymne national ou en
attikameks note simic qui veut dire là
d'où vient mon sens ses formes et ses
couleurs les clés de cette nouvelle
approche consultation dialogue et co
création par le fonctionnement naturel
de la profession d'architecte un
architecte et un peu un chef d'orchestre
le travail avec la communauté n'est pas
un obstacle
bien au contraire dans une démarche de
reconnaissance de l'autre l'
architecture accompagne les premières
nations et les inuit dans ses premiers
pas vers une réappropriation de son
environnement bâti cela se fait au
rythme des communautés dans une approche
non menaçante à l'icône de la réalité et
en respectant les principes de base de
leur culture pour les peuples
autochtones ce dialogue n'a rien
d'étrange non plus ses premières nations
inuits sont empreintes d'une tradition
de réciprocité nous pouvons échanger nos
savoir faire respectifs l' aéroport de
couacs tac est un magnifique exemple de
co création et d'échangé réciproque
il fait fascinant de constater
l'exercice de collaboration entre deux
artistes
jodi picoult lola inouk est l'artisan
bernard paquet québécois
bel esprit de partage et la volonté de
toucher un plus grand public a permis de
donner une voix aux peuples oubliés et
ainsi à l'oeuvre d'art de devenir plus
grande qu elle même ses délicates
culture d'une maman béluga et ses petits
engage les passants alors qu'il se
trouve à quoi que tu as qu à penser aux
liens sacrés avec la nature avec la
chasse avec la nourriture
pour les visiteurs c'est une invitation
dialogue au respect pour les inuits un
symbole fort de leur volonté de se
réapproprier leur espace de vie
un autre exemple avec un look tout yak
la station canadienne de recherche en
extrême arctique
réunis sous un même toit technologies
contemporaines et savoir inuit les
espaces publics ont été disposés
conformément aux principes inuit des
espaces libres ouverts interreliés le
cas geek et blue communautaire de
l'arctique de l'ouest a inspiré des
structures qui se retrouve autant à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur
par sa présence physique et symbolique
et l'intégration des arts à même la
bâtisse le cas geek amène une présence
rassurante pour les habitants de la
communauté
cela facilite leur intégration il
suscite des échanges entre inuit et non
autochtone
après une longue période d'isolation
n'oublions pas l'environnement bâti la
preuve d'une présence semaine elle
participe à un mode de vie et soutient
le tissu social cette volonté de
décolonisation en douceur on la retrouve
dans un bâtiment plus petit à vocation
thérapeutique
le centre-droit one située en territoire
nettement à gap et gagne est un centre
de réadaptation pour jeune autochtone l'
architecture du centre s'inspire des
abris traditionnel algonquin et cherche
ainsi à faciliter l'intégration des
traditions de guérison autochtone cela
se fait très concrètement avec
l'aménagement des espaces de ce mot jean
paul ification là où peuvent faire
brûler de la sauge et autres herbes
purificatrice c'est en redonnant sa
place d'un an
à l' architecture des premières nations
que des identités fragilisé après des
décennies d'acculturation et de
colonisation pourront se rebâtir
s'épanouir dans un environnement plus
fidèles à leur culture de cette manière
le 103 guan en évoquant la culture
algonquine créer un environnement
propice à la réappropriation culturelle
à la reconstruction de l'estimé de soi à
la fierté
nous comptons canada permis les peuples
autochtones au moins une cinquantaine de
nation survivante pour 630 communauté
sans compter les 8 94 leur incroyable
diversité est un trésor à préserver à
récréer à célébrer l'architecturé
devenue une ambassadrice de bonne
volonté auprès des communautés
autochtones l'architecturé implique tout
le monde artiste citoyen autorités les
architectes eux mind avec le don de
sculpter le vide de l'espace pour ces
peuples oubliés du temps le temps est
venu de redonner à l' architecture son
droit de promouvoir la culture au même
titre que la cuisine la peinture les
champs la spiritualité l'environnement
bâti doit parler de nous et nous parler
nous rappeler notre passé notre vision
de l'avenir c'est la connaît et c'est là
qu'on meure l'environnement bâti c'est
ce qu'il reste de nous quand nous
partons autant que ce soit un voyage
coloré passionnant dans un environnement
sensible à nos particularités
merci qui nagent comme maintenant
[Applaudissements]